at a Kurdish military base in Northeast
Syria overnight the soldiers looked
remarkably relaxed given what they now
face the American troops who were
alongside them have moved out and their
enemy Turkey is set to attack but
speaking to Sky News the regional
commander said they are as prepared as
they can be and will defend their land
the people are already working and
moving towards the border area in order
to create a human shield against any
Turkish invasion and I think everyone is
also working to prepare itself for any
future operation
I think our advice would be for the
people to to take care of themselves and
their families and trust the same
democratic forces to defend them and to
protect them to the north over the
border the Turkish military is now
massing through the day tanks were moved
along the roads and into position
soldiers arrived in border towns in
fleets of coaches all this just 48 hours
after the US president stepped aside
militarily and controversially giving
space for his ally Turkey to attack his
other ally the Kurds
artillery is now in place with sights
set on Syrian Kurdish positions on the
other side for Turkey the enemy over
there are terrorists they wanted to
destroy for decades but they're the same
people who've been fighting the Islamic
state alongside the Americans and the
British and in the Syrian town of
Qamishli they reminded the world of that
[Music]
wounded Kurdish fighters marching
carrying posters of their dead comrades
past the UN offices their call was for
the international community to stop the
Turkish incursion it was a blunt message
- for Donald Trump
we fought alongside you we've almost
defeated Isis don't abandon us yet in
Ankara the Turkish Vice President framed
the incursion as humanitarian in part a
space to repatriate Syrian refugees but
a chance - to remove an old enemy Turkey
will not accept the creation of a terror
corridor or a terror state right next to
its borders under any circumstances
whatever the cost well they've been
coming down towards the border through
the day a couple more here now in the
sense that we're getting is that even if
Donald Trump does decide to make some
sort of a u-turn here in Turkey this
time they really are ready to move in
but as the military units gather
president Trump's yo-yoing has continued
he's warned against turkey overreaching
with disproportionate force it could be
too late the suggestion is an invasion
could be imminent and another phase of
this complicated war would begin mark
stone sky news on the turkey-syria
border